lui lui lave une star ce week end c'est
énorme et ça où il a vu la star vie que
je rêve de voir c'est vrai 6 alors si
demain franchement s'il ya une personne
que j'ai envie de rencontrer cl mayrand
si cécile bassi bassi à quelles fins
qu'en face ils calent fin à des à des
fins aller à des à des fins amical
article oui à des fins amical amical
j'ai besoin d'amis oui madame amaury non
oui vous ils vont venir vous chercher
pour le casting pour roba ou un pour le
laisser rêver nous alimenter au plus
tard alors oui là je vous le dis il a vu
la star que je voulais comment ça s'est
passé avant qu'on voit les photos noms
mais surtout j'ai rencontré de cette
star planétaire gare du nord à 100
mètres de la gare du nord le quartier le
moins glamour de paris alors c'est une
star quand même j'adore genre compte
réel il paraît que c'était sa soeur qui
l'accompagné mais j'y connais rien vous
étiez quoi au défilé de d'olivier
rousteing évalue aussi également nos
rangs je rentrais de voix chez vous je
rentrais de voyage je passais sur le
trottoir de manière complètement hasard
tombé et je tombe sur garder regardez
kim kardashian c'est toi qui a pris la
photo
oui c'est toi le cadre et la polio ouais
elle a tenu et folle j'adore à mais
j'adore franchement j'adore ça s'arrose
ah ouais j'adore il ya sa soeur aussi
hollande
mon cul en vinyle cm et séoul et les
duels sont arrivés comme ça mais ça
l'est où ces gens là mais je ne sais pas
il s'engouffrait dans cet immeuble de
photographes qui attendaient et mais je
la rencontre gardena alors que moi je
déteste la télé réalité vous êtes
reconnus tels m'a demandé à celle fille
j'ai dit non
alors ce qui était impressionnant de
tomber ça ou quelqu'un qui a l'habitude
de vivre 24 heures sur 24 devant sur des
appareils photos soient des caméras elle
s'arrête 5 secondes et les isles est
vraiment elle sait aussi naturel que
pour moi mettre le pass navigo à bukavu
café voilà que vous faisiez la photo oui
mais il y avait du monde ou pas aux
personnes mais avait quelques
photographes qui attendaient donc il
devait être au courant mais moi je suis
à l'aller alors on me dit de l'oreille à
l'aller où c'est pas la mer à la messe
de kanye west et sarah brianna men mais
s'est fait à barbès y avait investi il y
avait des personnalités fn aura kyi mais
dont il est roustan absolument
d'où le nom de marie doré ce concert
c'est le fort moi j'adhère totalement je
trouve ça cool à la baisse le quai ouest
où j'avais autre chose à faire tout est
est ce que tu prends en photo dédicacée
à l'émission l'envoyer directement à moi
et à ma job c'est que j'adore kim
kardashian voilà way s'est mis en mode
paparazzi la de guinée diact